I definitely think the human journey is
characterized by a desire to expand what
we can see we've had this uncanny
ability to engineer solutions for our
perceptual limitations so we couldn't
see in the microwave spectrum other
modalities within the electromagnetic
spectrum and we create these tool radar
scanners and so on and so forth these
instruments that allow us to all of a
sudden perceive other dimensions beyond
what our senses can usually detect we've
also can only experienced moments before
it's gone all right and with tools like
the camera digital lens the iris all of
a sudden we are extending the eye to
freeze-frame to hold in stasis the
passing moment effectively immortalizing
the most elusive thing we know which is
the now
that's why I love cameras this one
you